henri guaino écartée par les
républicains et 14 candidats espèrent
devenir député de la 3e circonscription
des yvelines c'est 5 de moins qu'en 2012
à l'époque l'ancien conseiller de
nicolas sarkozy l'avait remportée face à
la candidate socialiste fabienne galgon
bilbo avec près de 62% des suffrages
exprimés
critiqué pour son manque
d'investissement sur le terrain henri
guaino n'a pas été investi une nouvelle
fois par son parti le maire du chesnay
philippe brillault lui a reçu le soutien
des ténors locaux et l'air candidat pour
la sixième fois d'affilée cet ancien
médecin fait figure de favori pour
l'élection sur un territoire acquis à la
droite depuis plusieurs décennies il
souhaite notamment faire une campagne
pour une fiscalité incitative et sur un
meilleur accès au logement et après
avoir été chasseur philippe brillault
est désormais chasser notamment par le
conseiller régional francilien
nicolas tardy joubert soutenu par le
parti chrétien-démocrate de jean
frédéric poisson lui aussi proche de la
manif pour tous
ce candidat classé divers droite
pourrait récolter de nombreuses voix
dans plusieurs villes où françois fillon
est arrivé en tête au premier tour de la
présidentielle comme à bougival
hors-concours une concurrence à droite
qui pourrait faire les affaires de
béatrice piron la candidate de la
république en marche se présente pour la
première fois à une élection
elle espère surfer sur la vague
présidentielle et du renouveau pour
remporter cette circonscription
urbanisées où le chômage ne dépasse pas
les 9 % une première aussi pour la
candidate du front national stéphanie de
gonneville membre de l'équipe de
campagne de marine le pen il y a cinq
ans elle essaiera de faire mieux qu'en
2012 et les 7,1 pour cent du fn
recueillies sur la circonscription à
gauche les espoirs sont nombreux aussi
le parti socialiste a réussi à sceller
un accord local avec europe ecologie les
verts le parti radical de gauche et le
parti communiste pour soutenir nicolas
eu conseiller municipal des
clayes-sous-bois reste à savoir si cette
unité de la gauche suffira pour se
hisser au second tour de l'élection
comme il y a cinq ans autre binôme qui
souhaitent s'immiscer dans cette course
à la députation celui de la france
insoumise et son candidat alexandre
langlois novice en politique il devrait
largement faire mieux que la candidate
du front de gauche en 2012 qui n'avait
récolté qu à peine
plus de 2% des voix le 11 juin jour du
premier tour de l'élection près de 85
mille électeurs sont appelés à voter
pour départager au total 14 candidats